Y cuando despierto,
tengo el más terrible sabor de boca.
El sabor es tan terrible que no lo puedo describir con palabras,
pero lo puedo dibujar.
(Risas)
Me encanta dormir.
Y cuando duermo, prefiero dormir de cucharita.
He dormido de cucharita por casi 20 años,
pero en todo este tiempo nunca supe
qué hacer con el brazo de abajo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Lo único...
lo único que hace que el dormir sea más complicado
que tratar de dormir en un avión
es cuando tienes niños pequeños.
Se aparecen en tu cama como a las 4 a. m.,
con esa falsa excusa de "tuve una pesadilla".
(Risas)
Y claro que te sientes mal porque son tus hijos
y los dejas subirse a tu cama.
Y tengo que admitirlo, al comienzo son muy lindos, cálidos y cómodos.
Pero apenas comienzas a dormirte, de manera inexplicable ellos...
(Risas)
comienzan a rotar.
Nos gusta llamar esta posición el helicóptero.
(Risas)
Si algo está profundamente grabado en tu conciencia,
harán falta menos detalles para crear una reacción emocional.
(Risas)
¿Por qué esta ilustración funciona?
Funciona porque como lectores
somos muy buenos para rellenar los espacios en blanco.
Cuando dibujan existe el concepto del espacio negativo.
La idea es que en vez de dibujar el objeto,
se dibuja el espacio que lo rodea.
Los cuencos en este dibujo están vacíos.
Pero la tinta negra incita a tu cerebro a proyectar comida en el vacío.
Lo que vemos aquí no es un búho volando.
Lo que vemos es un par de pilas AA
sobre un dibujo sin sentido,
y animo la escena moviendo una lámpara de mesa de arriba a abajo.
(Risas)
La imagen realmente solo existe en tu mente.
Entonces, ¿cuánta información nos hace falta para crear esta imagen?
Mi objetivo como artista es usar la menor cantidad posible.
Intento alcanzar un nivel de simplicidad tal
que al eliminar un elemento más,
todo el concepto colapsaría.
Por eso mi herramienta favorita como artista es la abstracción.
He inventado un sistema que llamo el abstractómetro
y funciona así.
Tomas cualquier símbolo, por ejemplo, el corazón y la flecha,
que la mayoría de nosotros entenderíamos como el símbolo del amor,
y como artista puedo dibujar esto
usando cualquier nivel de realismo o abstracción.
Si lo hago muy realista, nos parecerá grotesco.
(Risas)
Si me voy hacia el otro extremo y lo hago muy abstracto,
nadie tendrá idea de lo estamos viendo.
Tengo que encontrar el lugar perfecto en la escala,
y en este caso, está por el medio.
Una vez que hemos reducido la ilustración a una forma más simple,
todo tipo de conexiones se hacen posibles.
Y eso nos permite tener nuevos ángulos en la historia.
(Risas)
Lo que me gusta hacer
es tomar imágenes de áreas culturales remotas y combinarlas.
Ahora, con referencias más atrevidas...
(Risas)
me divierto más.
Pero sé que eventualmente las cosas se harán tan imprecisas
que comenzaré a confundir a algunos de Uds.
Así que como diseñador es realmente clave tener un buen entendimiento
del vocabulario visual y cultural de la audiencia.
Con esta ilustración, un comentario sobre las Olimpíadas en Atenas,
asumo que el lector del "New Yorker"
tendrá una idea rudimentaria del arte griego.
Si no, la imagen no funciona.
Si lo tienen, incluso apreciarán los pequeños detallas,
como este diseño de latas de cervezas en la parte inferior del jarrón.
(Risas)
Un debate recurrente que tengo con los editores de revistas,
que son por lo general gente de palabras,
es que la audiencia, o sea Uds.,
están más dispuestos a aceptar cambios radicales en las ilustraciones
que lo que creen.
Lo único que me parece frustrante es que con frecuencia me obligan
a usar un pequeño número de clichés visuales repetidos hasta el cansancio
porque son más seguros.
Como el hombre de negocios que va subiendo una escalera
y esta se mueve y se transforma en un gráfico de la bolsa de valores,
y cualquier cosa con el signo del dólar, que siempre es bueno.
(Risas)
Si en la audiencia tenemos personas que toman decisiones editoriales,
quiero darles un consejo.
Cada vez que se publica una ilustración como esta,
muere un bebé panda.
(Risas)
Literalmente.
(Aplausos)
¿Cuándo un cliché visual es bueno o malo?
Es una línea muy delgada.
Y realmente depende de la historia.
En el 2011, durante el terremoto y el tsunami en Japón,
pensaba en una carátula.
Y pensé en todos los símbolos clásicos:
la bandera de Japón,
"La gran ola" de Hokusai, una de las mejores ilustraciones que existe.
Y luego la historia cambió
cuando perdieron el control de la situación en la planta de Fukushima.
Recuerdo estas imágenes en la tele de los trabajadores en los trajes hazmat
caminando hacia el sitio,
y lo que me sorprendió fue lo silencioso y lo sereno que se veía.
Así que quise crear la imagen de una catástrofe silenciosa.
Esta fue la imagen que se me ocurrió.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Lo que quiero crear es un "Eureka" para Uds., para los lectores.
Desafortunadamente, eso no quiere decir
que me dé un "Eureka" cuando creo estas ilustraciones.
No estoy en el escritorio
con esa famosa bombilla que se me prende en la cabeza.
Lo que de hecho ocurre es un proceso muy lento,
poco atractivo, de decisiones de diseño mínimas
que luego, con suerte, me conducen a una buena idea.
Un día, en el tren, intentaba descodificar
las reglas gráficas de las gotas en una ventana.
Finalmente, me di cuenta,
"Ah, es el fondo borroso al revés
dentro de una imagen nítida".
Pensé, guao, qué interesante,
pero no tenía idea de qué hacer con eso.
Más tarde, de vuelta a Nueva York,
hice esta ilustración de estar estancado en el tráfico en el puente de Brooklyn.
Es muy molesto, pero también un tanto poético.
Más tarde me di cuenta
de que podía tomar estas dos ideas y combinarlas en esta idea.
Lo que quiero no es mostrar una imagen realista.
Pero, quizás como la poesía,
hacerlos conscientes de que tienen esta imagen con Uds.,
que lo he desenterrado
y he logrado que se den cuenta de que llevaban consigo esta imagen.
Pero como la poesía, es un proceso delicado
y no creo que sea eficiente o escalable.
Quizás la habilidad más importante para un artista
sea realmente la empatía.
Necesitas un conocer tu arte...
(Risas)
creatividad...
--gracias--
para que se te ocurran ideas como esta.
Pero luego te tienes que distanciar
y mirar lo que has creado desde la perspectiva del lector.
Trato de llegar a ser un mejor artista siendo un mejor observador de imágenes.
Para ello, comencé un ejercicio
que llamo ilustraciones del domingo,
que quiere decir que los domingos, tomo cualquier objeto de la casa
y trato de ver si el objeto me genera una idea
que no tiene nada que ver con el propósito original del objeto.
Usualmente, me quedo en blanco por un buen rato.
El único truco que eventualmente funciona es si abro mi mente
y reviso todas las imágenes que tengo guardadas allí
para ver si algo encaja.
Si eso ocurre, solo agrego unas cuantas líneas de tinta para conectar...
para preservar este breve momento de inspiración.
La mayor lección
es que la magia realmente no ocurre en el papel.
Ocurre en la mente del lector.
Cuando tus expectativas y tu conocimiento chocan con mis intenciones artísticas.
Su interacción con una imagen,
su habilidad para leer, cuestionar, molestarse, aburrirse o inspirarse
gracias a una imagen
es tan importante como mi contribución artística.
Porque eso es lo que transforma una declaración artística
en un verdadero diálogo creativo.
Así que su habilidad para leer las imágenes
no es solo increíble,
es lo que hace que mi arte sea posible.
Y por eso, les doy las gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Vítores)
Gracias.
(Risas)